jersey stand up actually tri-state area  road trip time this Friday Black Friday  I will be back at my Pop's shop from 11  to 2. can't wait to see all of you  selfies q a we've got a special empathy  sparkling wine that is only exclusive at  Wine Library I'm signing those bottles  come through if you're in the area I  know a lot of you get back to Jersey for  Thanksgiving I know a lot of people will  be in New York Pennsylvania Connecticut  come through 11 to 2 p.m Link in my bio  leave a comment if you're coming I want  to make sure I get to see all of you uh  I'm excited it's just so fun to see all  of you in person I love jamming opposite  I love being in my own stomping grounds  uh it should be a lot a lot a lot of fun  I love you I'll see you have a great  great Thanksgiving if I don't see you  but I'd love to see you this Friday Link  in the bio come see me